[Music]
we've never been the Grammys before I
mean when we were they were like you're
gonna give Best Rock Album don't worry
about it don't even think about it as
woman comes up to me and hands me the
ballot and goes oh by the way we have to
know shows and they're like one band
sign here and obviously David Bowie who
is nominated is not here and I'm like
what happens if there's a no-show like
don't worry about it don't worry about
it sure enough David Bowie wins you're
accepting the award like everybody for
first rock Grammy ever ever and it's
like you know Steve boys a huge
inspiration of ours like I was you know
in your kind of like caught off guard
like do you say something on its behalf
to you just shut up and now speaking on
behalf yeah I would Bowie are the change
I would like you to know yes we're in
our 20s and we don't deserve this I mean
that was the first time we held the
Grammy was you know accepting it on
behalf of David Bowie's can't plan for
any of this stuff man because we just
get [ __ ] over with these like
harvested